we have brought some of the insects and
our creatures that you deal with right
because eventually we want to have
animals on the animal presentation yes
well okay okay you trust me right
we just met today but you trust me no I
really don't know we have no reason to
yeah we have no reason to trust twitch
it put your hand out here okay I got
something that I know are you seriously
I don't want to get stung am I getting
it no no no this is this is you know
about it's not safe as you can do right
now that's a bird eating spider it's an
enormous spider okay oh and as long as
you don't really make any sudden moves
them in it right they're gonna be chit
oh yeah been a minute and big things
enormous things and then of course we
have this little guy here this is a
vinegaroon you know wait what is that
why would you put that near the other
one one of these has no bite one of them
does you guys know which is which this
one looks really scary right here let's
turn them don't touch him you ready
gonna do no no I have those things in
the front of its face that sorts keep
rabbits food and shove it into its mouth
okay and look how calm that spiders
being yeah as you're being calm right
yeah I am never been this still in my
entire life where is the stinging part
of the spider can you push in on that I
was like right on your wrist right there
but you do min on that please oh yeah
they had okay enormous fangs Conan right
there all right don't touch him I'm not
going to I don't want you to get bitten
okay you still away mom yeah clearly you
care a lot about my well-being but look
at how good this little vinegar is being
okay whispering over here okay Jeff God
you don't have out Jeff you don't have
to do anything you don't want me to I
brought a little Malcolm with me yeah I
know yeah little kid coyote would be
really upset with big kid coyote
epidemic yeah if you'd have to do
anything you don't want to do you don't
have to do anything you don't want to do
you're free to go at any time you don't
no sudden moves got a child on the way
no sudden movements have to take this
guy these are creepy crawlies right
wobbuff elk you come on let's get these
you'll be more interesting the creepy
crawlies slimy slithering right no no
thank you let's let's getting those out
get this guy honey no no
movements I got him I got him I got him
oh boy don't play me don't put me down
all right
you